i'm sure this last six months have been
overwhelming to you just because you've
had eyes of tammy faye and spiderman no
way home and tick tick boom which were
all filmed you know at different times
but they all came out around the same
time i'm sure you were like oh my god
make it stop we all enjoyed it but for
you but a bit different we've already
touched on the first two a little bit
tonight so um i want to move into a
conversation about tick tick boom but
before we do
it's gonna be really cool to see
uh the y number uh on this screen so
let's let's take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
9
[Music]
no one cares
we sang
[Music]
over and over and over
[Music]
when we
emerged
from the ymca
three o'clock son had made the grass
[Music]
i thought hey
what a way to spend the day
hey
what a way to spend the day
i make a vow
right here and now
i'm gonna spend
my time this way
when i was 16
michael and i
got parts in west side
at white plains high
three o'clock went to rehearse
in the gym
mike played duck who did not sing fine
with him we sang got a rocket
in your pocket and the jets are gonna
have their day
tonight over and over
[Music]
nine o'clock stars
[Music]
[Music]
i wonder now
am i cut out to spend my time this way
i'm 29.
michael and i
[Music]
[Music]
come to your senses defenses are not the
way to go
[Music]
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over till i get it wrong
[Music]
[Music]
i think hey
what a way to spend a day
[Music]
i make a vow
right here and now
i'm gonna spend
my time this way
i'm gonna spend
my time
[Music]
[Applause]
i love that i mean first of all
watching that makes you understand why
myron and andrew the two editors of this
movie got an oscar nomination because
the ending is
spectacular
but when i'm watching that and looking
at the different camera angles close-ups
further away shots
this was obviously an overnight maybe it
was more than one overnight i don't know
but how do you summon that emotion
for as many takes and as many angles and
as many shots as it required
um
[Music]
so
god so so
i
i just i cried watching that because
it's not because of what i'm doing but
because
um
because it's
[Applause]
it's
i'm singing for my mother in it
and um
she's so grateful that i got to
i got to do that and i got to
share that with people who watch the
film
it's uh
it's a bit much because
that is just
um
that's the loss that's that's that's
lost that's that's the
biggest loss i've ever experienced in my
life and trying to deal with it and
trying to
understand
how to move through it and move on with
it and
the kind of process that jonathan
is going through in that scene is that
process is how do i meet this loss of my
friend
how do i meet this loss of my best
friend and um and so many people around
me
and how do i go on doing the thing that
i think i'm supposed to do which is
right music is that enough
um is that love
uh it's short and it's sacred this life
and we're here and then we're not and
how do we know what we're supposed to be
doing and am i cut out for it and what's
the way i want to spend my time
and
i think at that moment jonathan gets the
message from
from robin's character michael and i
love the
the lin and the editors but that cut of
um
grown-up robin coronel michael and
grown-up john in the workshop with
michael responding to the superb
workshop and then looking at his friend
and then john receiving that look and
going
okay
i'm gonna keep doing it because it's not
just
for me it's it's for my community it's
for you it's for you that i love
um and i think that is the connected
piece in that song that jonathan
gets to where he's like
i can justify doing it if it means that
i'm advocating
for something bigger than just me
that i'm advocating for life that i'm
advocating for
dignity and
sorry i'm advocating for the sacredness
of
of all of us
um and especially people who are not
treated as sacred by
the world and by the culture and that's
who jonathan was surrounded by and
so for me it was
it was a message in a bottle
from my mum
before my mum
for jonathan
for jonathan's community a lot of whom
were lost during the aids epidemic it
was this kind of um container of grief
and of longing for more life as prior
walter would say in angels in america it
was prior also it was for tony kushner
it was
so
accessing that
was i still have it here it's here it's
alive in me and it's not it's not um
it's what makes life worth living the
awareness that we're only here for a
moment and we're gonna lose everyone
that we love
means that we get we better be here
fully and i think that is where jonathan
rises
you know that's where he gets to in that
song so
we got on the second take the close-up
like it was fine after the second thing
but the second thing so i got just to be
technical for a second so i don't keep
crying um
we start i asked lynn and alice our
amazing cinematographer mike fuchs our
great camera operator
to start um
on tight on me whatever that mastered
kind of tight performance shot would be
because i know that
crazy stuff happens in the first few
takes in this magic usually when someone
just shows the first take is usually
magic and then the same thing is usually
match magic
and i knew i wanted to sing it live as
well i knew i wanted to make sure that
we got it live because it was going to
be broken and it was going to be raw and
it was going to be rough and it was
going to be
found it's a spontaneous song you know
it's not written he's just making it up
so i had to feel like
so i had to sing it live and that was
week one of shooting and i hated lynne
so much
i saw it on the schedule and i was like
what's this and he was like buddy it's
great you're gonna get it under your
belt and you're gonna move and then
you're gonna the rest is be a cakewalk
and i was like no no no no motherfucker
what is this
[Applause]
[Music]
i was like what's the real reason don't
bullshit a bullshitter
and he paused and he kind of looked me
in the eye and was like okay i think i'm
now understanding who andrew is i can't
just kind of play kate
and he's like well we're going to lose
the location as we should be in the
first week
and i was like thank you fuck you i have
to go
i have to go and prepare and uh and
anyway but he but the two things were
true it was we were gonna lose the
location
but also
the first reason was also true in the
sense that like it did feel like this
mountain and julie
larson was there that night john's
john's sister our producer
um
and there was there was a kind of a mat
whenever julie was was with us there was
oh fuck i don't want to cry again man um
but there was another spiritual
dimension
that was added to to the set
um and even when she wasn't with us we
summoned her we called her in kind of
thing um
so so yeah take two
i i kind of came to after the take in
that great way that you rarely get as an
actor where you kind of wake up out of a
scene or a moment you go oh i think
something just happened i wasn't aware
of it i was very very locked in
and lin lin kind of came out and he was
like know wiping away whatever
and that was always a good sign that
alice was like i mean that's it and like
the sound mixer was like tom was like
got it i'm like it's like when does a
sound mix a dude like it's like you
don't that's it and it was cool it was
one of those great moments on set and
and and i'm i'm i'm hesitant i usually
be hesitant to kind of say oh yeah we
nailed it but actually
it transcended nailing the scene it was
like i got to commune with my mom i got
to commune with john and they filmed it
and i forgot they were filming it and i
got to just
offer offer that offer her to the world
in a way offer my where she lives in my
heart in that scene
and then the rest was
a lot easier yeah and it's beautiful to
have that opportunity
[Applause]